-Republicans have been
wallowing after yet another
string of defeats
in key battleground states
on Tuesday,
as the front runner
for their party's
presidential nomination,
Donald Trump, faced more
legal trouble,
with his daughter Ivanka
taking the stand
in their New York fraud trial.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Donald Trump's daughter Ivanka
arrived at the Manhattan
courthouse today
and took the witness stand
in the Trump company's
civil fraud trial,
a scenario Trump was
reportedly desperate to avoid --
I'm assuming because Ivanka is,
in his eyes, the most competent
and thus most knowledgeable
member of the family.
There's no way Trump trusted
his two bearded, oblong bozos
with any real information,
but Ivanka
could get him in trouble.
Because while Don Jr.
was in the woods
posing for the cover of his
country folk Christmas album,
and Eric was in Brazil
having his gums lowered,
I'm willing to bet Ivanka
was in the room for everything.
For example,
maybe she could explain
what the hell her father
was talking about on Monday
when he pulled out a piece
of paper during his testimony
and said it would
clear his name.
So, on top of everything else,
Donald Trump has never seen
an episode of "Law & Order."
"Your Honor, may I present
non-submitted evidence
from the witness stand?"
"Do whatever you want.
Courtrooms are famously
loose with the rules."
[ Laughter ]
"In fact, if you -- if I ever
say anything you don't like,
feel free to object to me."
[ Laughter ]
I'm honestly dying to know
what that document was
because it was no doubt
incredibly stupid.
[As Trump] Your Honor,
I have in my possession
the fortune from a cookie
obtained last night
at Mr. Chang's on 58th Street.
It reads as follows.
[ Clears throat ]
"What you believe,
you can make true."
I accept your apology.
I accept, and I believe
I'm free to go.
[Normal voice]
Honestly, I'm just shocked
Trump didn't pull out
some of the courtroom sketches
that have been released
so he could complain
about them.
Trump's former press secretary
called one particular sketch
of Trump "a travesty" and said
it looks nothing like him.
Now, I'll admit,
it doesn't look a ton...
[ Laughter ]
It doesn't look a ton like Trump
until you widen out
and see the hands.
[ Laughter ]
They nailed the hands!
[ Cheers and applause ]
By the way, the same artist
who drew that sketch
also did one of El Chapo.
And yet somehow, a guy who
shares a courtroom sketch artist
with a notorious
drug kingpin
remains the GOP front-runner
for president.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, recent polls suggest
he's in a dead heat
with Joe Biden.
So Democrats
were steeling themselves
for some big losses on Tuesday
in several key bellwether states
like Virginia.
I know a clip package is coming,
so let's just get it over with.
The polling is awful.
I'm sure Democrats got crushed.
Just hit me with the bad news
so I can go sulk.
-Overnight, Democrats
celebrating
a series of key victories.
-Big wins for Democrats
and for abortion rights.
-In Ohio, voters have decided
overwhelmingly to make abortion
a right
under the state constitution.
In Virginia, CNN projects
Democrats will gain full control
of the state legislature.
-Meanwhile, in Kentucky,
it was Democratic
Governor Andy Beshear
defeating the state's
Republican attorney general,
Daniel Cameron,
who had been backed
by former
President Donald Trump.
-Well, allow me to quote
the great Edward R. Murrow
and say, "What the [bleep]
is going on?"
You're telling me Biden is
losing to Trump in the polls,
but a Democrat
just won reelection
against a Trump-backed candidate
in Kentucky?
You're telling me Trump, the guy
who stocked the Supreme Court
with '80s movie villains
with the explicit goal
of overturning Roe v Wade,
is leading the polls in Ohio,
where voters
just overwhelmingly approved
a ballot measure
to protect abortion rights?
This [bleep]
makes so little sense,
even Steve Kornacki's big board
last night said, "I give up."
[ Laughter ]
One thing's for sure --
standing up for abortion rights
and bodily autonomy
wins elections.
Voters are clearly furious
about losing Roe,
and in even supposedly red
states like Kentucky and Ohio,
they've been turning out
in large numbers
to protect
reproductive rights.
Ohio is the seventh state
to enshrine abortion rights
through a ballot initiative
since Roe was overturned,
and that includes battleground
states like Michigan
and even deep red states
like Kansas.
Abortion was also very much
on the ballot in Virginia,
where the Republican governor,
Glenn Youngkin,
was hoping to win full control
of the state legislature
so he could pass
a 15-week abortion ban.
Although you might not know that
from this Fox News interview
he did on Election Day.
-Welcome to Virginia.
It's Election Day,
and we are going to hold
our House and flip our Senate.
-Ever since the Supreme Court
overturned Roe v Wade,
Republicans have lost
most of those elections.
How is today going
to be different?
-Well, let me just begin
with the fact
that the biggest issue across
the Commonwealth of Virginia --
I hear it every day.
We've had 100 campaign stops.
...is inflation and jobs
and concerns about what Biden
is doing to our economy.
-It's so telling that these guys
spent 50 years laser-focused
on their number-one goal
of overturning abortion rights,
and then as soon
as they do it,
not only do
they not brag about it,
they'd rather talk about
literally anything else.
"So, what's your position
on abortion?"
"Well, I think first of all,
we have to talk about jobs."
"My question
was about abortion."
"Then, of course, we need
to talk about inflation."
"Okay. But what about abortion?"
"And then, of course,
what we really need to focus on
is Hunter Biden's laptop."
"I'm asking about abortion."
"And I will get to that.
But first, what do you think
of my shiny red vest?"
[ Laughter ]
I stole it off
a Carnival cruise.
It was also evident in the way
they were coping last night
that Republicans
are having a hard time
coming to terms with the fact
that their position on abortion
is deeply unpopular
with the majority of voters.
Here's Fox host Sean Hannity
trying to wrap his brain
around why the issue
keeps hurting Republicans.
-Democrats are trying to scare
women into thinking Republicans
don't want abortion legal
under any circumstances.
-First of all, if Democrats
were trying to scare people,
they would just show them
this courtroom sketch.
[ Laughter ]
But yeah, I wonder where voters
could possibly
have gotten the notion
that Republicans want
to outlaw abortion,
aside from
all the GOP-led states
that have outlawed abortion,
or the GOP politicians who say
they want to outlaw abortion,
or the new
Speaker of the House
who sponsored a bill
to outlaw abortion
and who's so conservative --
and this is real --
he said last year that he
and his 17-year-old son monitor
each other's porn intake.
That's real.
He said that.
They apparently use an app
that sends each other a report
when they look at porn,
so they can hold
each other accountable.
Can you imagine knowing --
in real time --
when your dad
is watching porn?
The only thing I want to hear
from my dad
on the phone is, "Hold on.
Your mother wants to say hi."
[ Laughter ]
Also, how can you, sir,
use an app to monitor porn
when your name sounds
like a porn actor's name?
For example, the other day
I wanted to learn more
about his extreme
right-wing positions,
so I googled the words
"Johnson exposed."
And let's just say
the notifications
on the porn monitoring app
my dad made me install
were blowing up.
He called me right away,
and I said
I was working on "A Closer
Look," and then he said,
"You should take a closer look
at your priorities."
[ Laughter ]
Although it is fun to imagine
what it would have been like
if Joe Biden had that app on his
phone with his son Hunter.
Just mid press conference,
"Hold on a second.
My phone is buzzing."
[ Notifications chiming ]
Uh...Oh.
Ohh, dear God, Hunter.
Dear God, Hunter,
get a hold of yourself, man.
[ Laughter ]
Keep it on the laptop, buddy.
Anyway, where was --
Oh, yeah.
So, Republicans
were wallowing last night.
In fact, they were so bummed
that over on Newsmax,
former GOP senator
and presidential candidate
Rick Santorum was complaining
about the fact
that Democrats
sponsored ballot initiatives
to legalize marijuana
and enshrine abortion rights.
-We've seen this now
for the last several years.
And so a base election,
they, Democrats outspend,
and you put very sexy things
like abortion
and marijuana
on the ballot,
and a lot of young people
come out and vote.
-Ooh là là.
[ Laughter ]
Abortion and marijuana
are sexy now?
That's so weird to hear
coming from international
sex symbol Rick Santorum.
[ Laughter ]
You think marijuana is sexy?
Look, by the time
Ohio is cool with anything,
it's not sexy anymore.
Marijuana is for 50-year-olds
at a Dead & Company concert.
Marijuana is so tame compared to
what teens are into these days.
If Rick Santorum ever watched
so much as five minutes
of "Euphoria,"
he'd come out looking like
Rudy Giuliani.
I mean, that's what
I look like after
I watch one episode
of "Euphoria."
[ Laughter ]
[As Giuliani] Is this
what teens are really like?!
[Normal voice] What's clear
is that the GOP's various
culture war obsessions
and hostility to democracy
are turning off voters.
That doesn't mean Democrats
should feel comfortable.
Trump, as we've said before,
can still easily win,
unless, you know,
he ends up in jail,
which I have to say
would be...
-Very sexy.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, everybody. Thanks for
watching "A Closer Look."
And as a reminder,
my brother Josh and I
have started a new podcast
called "Family Trips
with the Meyers Brothers."
We hope you listen,
we hope you like it,
and see you soon.